and the welcome to our discussion and
here we are introduced please welcome
Bryan Keating
he's professor of physics associate
director of our Center and faculty
member at HSN he was Center for
Astrophysics and spaces brand
[Applause]
you are esteemed speakers tonight and
all just say a few words about each one
mm and then we'll get on to a couple of
prepared remarks and then and then James
will present the rebuttal to his brother
whatever sort wins over the first I'll
talk about the two the two panelists
tonight and then we hope to get a lot of
interaction from you folks we are live
streaming the event as we speak now no
questions coming in from all around the
world so first I'll introduce Freeman
Dyson who is truly a Lancome he is now
retired which has cut back the
productivity of the field of physics
dramatically but he was most recently
and most for longest duration professor
of physics at the storied Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton he's made
many contributions but of course one of
the one of the most notable is his
contribution to quantum electrodynamics
a field that is actually behind most of
the technology and greatest advances in
physics in the last seventy years
probably the most successful theory of
physics and that is judged by how
quantitatively and precisely it's been
tested he's written numerous books about
science in the general public and when I
was writing my own book which I won't
mention because I want to promote other
people's books tonight but I asked if he
would be so kind as to write me a blurb
and endorsement as my first book maybe
I'm only look now that I've got so many
children running around house and he
said absolutely not no I have no time
and I prefer to spend my time tackling
the vast stacks of books that have
already promised endorse these too but I
thought it was so genteel and so
actually memorized his polite rejection
and I use it now whenever I have to say
no to something I invoke the Dyson text
so get more of his beneath written so
many books the summer art sale out front
and on earth two years ago three years
ago almost you know he was here
discussing his his most recent book
tonight it'll be available you can ask
him questions about his his actual most
recent book which is a book of memoirs
based on letters to various people
luminaries but the things that are more
engineered letters to his sister's his
family and just the intimate portrayal
of the life of a scientist very very
wonderful book he's a fellow of the
American Physical Society a member of
the National Academy of Sciences here in
the United States at the Royal Society
of London and in 2000 he was awarded the
Templeton Prize for progress in religion
and in twenty twenty twelve whose word
the army conquer a prize that the August
meeting of the International mathematic
mathematical physics Congress and just
this year he won a very prestigious
award I'm blanking on the name for
science fiction Freeman keen running
with the award was this past this past
May yes yes it was a further four
outstanding science fiction writing
joining the two of us will be none of
them a professor Gregory Benford who is
who is in a lot of UC San Diego he was
born on January 30th 1941 January 30th
the twin twins are not only not always
evil and today he has one of his most
closest collaborators probably since
birth since before birth actually his
brother James also so Frank has been a
professor at UC Irvine since 1971 I've
known him for about half that time it
feels like he's a true legend in our
field publishing hundreds of papers in
the field condensed matter particle
physics plasmas mathematical physics and
several and biological conservation he's
been called a dumb Freeman Dyson I just
call him that
screenwriters also written incredible
books Easter the birthday project and
his classic novel which which which is
just a true classic takes place in part
used in the UCSD physics department in
the 1960s so I cannot be blamed for that
predates my life but it's just such a
treat to have the two of them here
tonight I have a bunch of questions I'll
ask are you really want any questions
from the two from all of you or the two
of them so please let us welcome Gregory
and Freeman Desmond
[Applause]
[Music]
so famously set by such brilliant
luminaries as Yogi Berra and others that
it's very difficult to make predictions
especially about the future and today's
2050 for 34 years in the future 35 years
in the future and the question of what
the deep future is like ifs you know
something on all of our minds is I think
maybe Woody Allen said I variation in
the future I plan on spending a lot of
time there and for you guys I think I
wonder first of all when you when you
think about the future just an overall
question I ask you this when you did a
podcast interview with me in the context
of if someone is going to tell you I
have good news and bad news
which do you want to hear first you told
me that your answer will are you
optimistic or pessimistic about the
world in general it was when I was born
in the nineteen thirties
[Music]
I think everything is getting better if
you travel widely which is so recently
about humanity's prospects in the deep
future maybe extending beyond 2050 for
but we you know even dire predictions
about the next 12 years for planet Earth
and some suggestions have been
popularized both by the two and by other
scientists working here at Scripps
Institution of Oceanography and
elsewhere about how one could you
engineer the planet to protect against
possibilities of impacts of global
global
change and other other things that may
happen the so I wanna talk about climate
change per se but I do want to talk
about this notion of you know
planet-wide engineering first of all
does the planet need us to do that you
know I get the sense the planet will go
on just fine maybe even if we're not
here here but do we have an obligation
and if so is there really hope and who
would do such a massive undertaking as
to engineer and tweak the planet to
perhaps protected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are but it's also so we're going to
do something I screaming out of sunlight
in the Arctic in the summer alone which
you can use aerosol at the very lowest
part of the or and they the point is
that if you lose the art surface as we
are rapidly then it's a positive
feedback in the system you get more dark
see you sort more heat and the system
just anyway
[Music]
their small-scale you think it's
fundamentally a physics problem
engineering problem a political problem
we hear a lot we had a recent you know
event where a famous paper was retracted
or how to be retracted from you know
basic front cover of nature magazine
for a change but it was it in some
people in the public this notion of
world science know whether it's real
scientists haven't decided and don't
make the policy wonks and so the
question is you know a is a soluble
problem because we can't solve it that
that changes the calculation of
you want to do for it is it solvable
using the laws of basic fundamental
physical science as we know it is it
practical to implement engineering and
is it politically palatable those are
all separate I think an equal to imagine
what kind of problem once said to me
that he didn't think we should try
writers to predict the future rather to
that's why there's so much negative and
dystopian science fiction but it's
certainly true that we are the species
the only one on the planet that moves
forward by falling somewhat and then
catching ourselves no other animal uses
such a risky locomotion those you know
the Safety's first animals are on for
relaxer look where it got them so we've
got to take really hard part of this
problem is how to reduce the risk I
think first by some real experiments
that look at alternative ideas such as
savers traveling into our Arctic or
Bailey as Europeans call it the Arctic
to see if you can stop the retreat of
the sea ice you use small perturbations
to see what the result is you couldn't
possibly think you could manage this
giant system without doing some kind of
experiments you can't do it all the
simulations I would also point out
religious family that in Genesis the
Lord gives how many of the job tending
the garden and the first injunction is
to mean the Beast which is about
so in your latest book of memoirs and
letter through letters Freeman talked
about the you know the great scientists
that you've had a chance to interact
with and one of the most touching you
know kind of passages but only in
retrospect you know we're talking of
optimism and pessimism and I said you
know the optimist builds the airplane
and the pessimist builds the parachute
you know you're you're talking about
meeting Stephen Hawking for the first
time and being you know horribly
depressed because you know he's gonna
die very soon this is 1970-71 of course
he went on to live until just March of
last year nearly fifty more years and
you say the only time that you really
felt you know believe is when you're in
his presence and you can only be
thinking about physics and energized by
the passion of this lightful soul as you
talked about so we have this notion of
scientist and I wonder if you guys could
you know sort of talk about you know
mentorship and sort of the role of
heroes and mentors and way that we think
about this you know in science science
is sort of an oral tradition of the
passed on through the generations and
you know we have we have students and
those students have students etcetera no
wonder you know throughout the years how
has how how's your philosophy of
mentorship and shaped by the people that
you have the benefit of learning from
and then and then secondly for both of
you being so creative how in your
opinion is it possible to teach somebody
to express the kind of creativity and so
forth that you have in your career
imagination as is the title of this
Center so first you know what were the
biggest people or events that shape your
philosophy of being a scientist and then
how you sort of inculcated that going
forward to train people
[Music]
yes peace
[Music]
so indeed I could say that some of the
people are most influenced we're here at
UCSD because my brother came here from
University of Oklahoma had good
physicists but we didn't have the likes
of Maria Mayer who told me nuclear
physics calculations and in my thesis
was generated the firm of try out the
energy now which is making great strides
to work fusion and learn blocking him
restricting me from running my thesis on
and then I gotta come to UC Irvine where
we started to be pro so people like that
ever tell her absolutely I was a postdoc
at Livermore I think he was incredibly
quick and seemingly anything and oh yes
we do
and here he was in the three-piece suit
whereupon he sat down in the chair he
stood up and took off the entire suit to
reveal he was where the swimming trunks
been to off his left calf and threw
himself is that you could train
personalities of Sciences and he said
most people yeah exactly so speaking of
the stereotype of you know disembodied
something just there's been a lot of
talk about the impact of artificial
intelligence and what that many do in
the future both for good and potential
harm to economies to industries etc some
are even applying the tools of
artificial intelligence to Kurt you know
certain certain entities out of business
physicists and that we some of the work
that we do can be outsourced if you will
to artificial intelligence and the
question that I have is very worried
about that are these things that concern
and should concern society I mean they
already are sort of being warned about
by the likes of Stephen Hawking and Elon
Musk
potential danger signs for all humanity
existence so you guys think about the
intelligence both I asked the once if
you will unconscious because we do
it's over and suddenly produces things I
always say you know we don't actually
have ideas ideas have us they arrive
figure them out consciously and Martin
said he never even thought of that of
that problem and I said the fact that
our minds concealed it from us a great
deal about creativity is a huge clue and
we don't understand and we certainly
don't know how to program so I hate not
optimistic we're really going to get
human intelligence instability married
is one entity that can do productive
things for us right away I passed yes
but the hard stuff is really hard this
theoretical physicist I think used
computers a lot but I don't so tend to a
comment I made earlier about this
question of whether or not you can teach
creativity can you teach it to students
who are into a music computer you know
let alone teach it to so fascinated by
both you guys are so productive and such
the luminous output how what is your
creative process
[Music]
yeah I also said the mascara I be able
to eye
I have a series of tricks I use every
success in the evening I don't fall sick
getting drowsy I review in my mind read
things
[Music]
that you just getting back to the craft
that you employ a writer for this most
recent book you have the material
sitting you know I think in your
mother's house or in your sisters all
these letters accrued from 1941
including one on the day of their birth
and so you compiled this on just some
residents for the audience perhaps is
another piece of advice to go along with
the kind of mental tax that corrected
presenting keep your letters because you
don't know they're gonna be you may need
them
[Music]
there's a couple of different
conversations that are going on you
mentioned that you've been hearing about
artificial intelligence for 17 years and
it certainly seems like things are
speeding up towards the so-called
alleged singularity I remember
programming on a very simple you know
8-bit computer or the kind of
question-and-answer game known as Eliza
meant to be a very very poor kids
version of a Turing machine that you
have things like that are so helpful as
the Microsoft pay-per-click I mean I
couldn't even a dream to them so but
Syria Mazama LexA and all sorts of other
artificial intelligence and they're
built in and that even my toddlers will
be aged with
something is accelerating young great
chronicles of the singularity when this
technological advance will be basically
driven by this positive feedback
mechanisms that greg spoke about in a
different context but do you this is
something that is is just continued to
be hyped up and then an outline question
will be something called the simulation
hypothesis popularized by several
physicists
actually up sometimes as far as we can
see I think I agree with that general
picture I recently listened to a piece
of software which had been programmed to
write like Johann Sebastian Bach and it
was a mystery short pieces and they
didn't sound like but it wasn't writing
the Brandenburg's pieces so I expect
there will be a surge in capabilities
but gentlemen telogen is going to be
much harder I think it's going to be an
experience like having him really good
diligent but largely an experienced
graduate student
[Music]
[Music]
you know that was true
[Laughter]
what I'd like to do all this to open
easily for two questions we'll do is
well have people sort of ask questions
and then I'll repeat it so everybody can
hear the audience and so for the benefit
here and they'd like a very broad swath
of the audience as we get a few of my
close friends and the only ones asking
questions so I really love to get a
broad spectrum they need to scare up I'm
curious
going off of the idea of artificial
intelligence and recognizing that it's
entirely possible that in the next 35
years the constant prediction being in
30 years will have comforted the
conversational AI it's it's like fusion
power it's it's the technology of the
future it always will be
but with conversationally I'm supposing
that it were to come into existence in
the next 35 years how would we recognize
it and how would how do you think that
we should treat it considering we may
have difficulty discerning between an
artificial intelligence and human
intelligence
first question no me a joke I have a
girl for that works the question is
about the prospects for both recognition
of the general conversation on
artificial intelligence me I believe
would be you know that you could have a
conversation with and if we're bored or
something like that you wouldn't know if
you're talking to a human or not more or
less the Turing test so that's the
question so what would be how would we
solve that
and how would we how do we interact
halogens is that designer question or is
it as a form recognition focusing on on
empathy because we all human history is
a record of failing to empathize with
other people that are not precisely like
us and as time is going on we've been
trying to get a better understanding of
who we are as human beings and what
makes a human being so in a similar
sense when we look at artificial
intelligence if we were to recognize it
as a live intelligence human
intelligence
like extension and one of the dreams
that also equally occurs in equal parts
dystopian science fiction and an utopian
is this implication perhaps too
[Music]
I thank you know just to take the
opposite side something like most
scientists yes I wonder where you think
will be in 35 years across the solar
system
and will it be humans out there or more
sophisticated AI is there a place for
humanity across the solar system
because this could be a while before me
we tune in for the lunar soup but ice
course sure
yeah there's so many great things in not
just zero for example some reasonable
arguments just by being an only fraction
of G to stop imposing such so that means
a rotating colony in low-earth orbit
[Music]
speaking about life in space I'll take
another question one second about aliens
it's always a hot topic Freeman and I
have talked briefly about so-called
Drake Equation are your impressions
about the prospects for extraterrestrial
life in general but then specifically
the technological format but generally
for advanced intelligence we should
realize that star formation began many
years ago here the center of the galaxy
has had time to develop civilizations
much longer than we have almost
so we started several programs to push
forward things with good idea but under
funded startups small little things
about the size of this powered by beam
to go to other stars to really break
through the hold speed I think better
than Rockets but what is it it is an
adventure steam and each one of these is
getting was 10 million a year just do
research each each boat so a freedom
would you like the same thing about
intelligent aliens and forth throughout
the galaxy
was me about our see most is early as
the way it
like Peter Lorre and they've been there
for several billion years and it's
afraid of us but we haven't explored
beneath the surface of Mars the easiest
thing to do is send Rovers into the over
200 caves we've already found on Mars
and that's a lot more possible out
comics talking about drilling through
ten kilometers of ice on Europa which
ain't gonna be done in this half of this
can you so the question is to Professor
Dyson whether
[Music]
[Music]
we was showing off different household
appliances that I'm known to use on
occasion whether was the Dyson Sphere
ball vacuum which there was another
question
[Music]
but would intelligent aliens want to
avoid humanity because of our
treacherous barbarous nature